Nach der klassischen urknalltheorie der big bang theory begann unser universum jahr vor etwa 13,8 zwei milliarden. Jahren mit dem urknall
gleichzeitig entstanden demnach auch raum und zeit wenn wir davon ausgehen hat
Sich die frage was war von dem. Urknall eigentlich erledigt aber mittlerweile gibt es weitere
Überlegungen dazu die sich auf die quantentheorie stützen und danach gibt es tatsächlich. Ein
Davor doch wie genau. Soll das aus ist das universum vielleicht aus dem nichts entstanden war es teil eines
Multiversums oder ist es noch oder markiert unser urknall lediglich das ende eines vorherigen
bezüglich universums die antworten jetzt wirklich zum science fiction herzlich willkommen
Macht wieder vielen dank für diesen spannenden themen vorschlag aus der web community wie ihr mitglied dort werden könnt ihr vater am ende des videos
Erste theorie das universum ist zyklisch vor ihm existiert. Ein anderes universum
Eine idee ist dass vor unserem universum
Ein anderes universum existiert hatte was sich immer weiter ausgedehnt hat bis es dann in sich zusammengefallen ist dann beginnt alles von vorn
So war also unser urknall der letzte moment eines anderen universums. Und vor diesem hatte wiederum
Ein anderes universum existiert vor dem urknall hätte somit also einen früheren, urknall gegeben. Und vor diesem einen
noch, früheren
Und so weiter doch dann gibt es eine weitere berechtigte frage die sich dem anschließt was war denn vor dem ersten urknall
Wenn, man, diesen gedanken mal weiter springen kommt man ja auch
Zu einer viel größeren frage die wir aber eigentlich
Damit meinen wie ist alles entstanden übrigens wem jetzt die antwort gott in den sinn kommt muss dann aber
Auch weiter fragen was war vor gott diese. Theorie des zyklischen universum es wird. Auch. Big points. Genannt und das heißt
So viel wie großer rückprall demnach hat auch. Eine kollision ein vorher
Und nachher heißt aber auch dass wir von dem gedanken uns verabschieden müssen dass der urknall der anfang von allem sein
Und darum dass alles zu belegen müsste die stringtheorie weiter. Ausgeklügelt werden zudem bräuchte es empirische belege der plan dazu
Satelliten teleskope könnten demnächst eventuell nachweisen dass die schwache mikrowellenstrahlung
Also das echo des urknalls in einem zyklischen universum andere
Eigenschaften hat als im herkömmlichen big bang universum zweite theorie unser universum ist teil eines umfassenden
Multiversums dahinter steckt die idee des sogenannten eckbüro tischen universums demnach ist unser universum. Noch lange nicht alles sondern nur. Ein
kleiner teil eines viel umfassenderen
Multiversums darin existieren viele einzelne universen die ab und an miteinander kollidieren das wäre dann quasi der moment des, ur kratz
und tatsächlich besteht hierbei die möglichkeit
Solch eine kollision nachzuweisen. Und zwar durch eine detaillierte untersuchung der kosmischen hintergrundstrahlung
Sehr wahrscheinlich es ist allerdings nicht dass wir irgendwann, solche hinweise finden werden
Um jetzt konkret auf die frage zu handen was jetzt genau vor dem
Urknall, wäre wäre die antwort. Dann, ein multiversum in dem prozess zum urknall
Geführt haben doch letztendlich ist die frage damit auch nicht final geklärt
Denn mit dieser theorie schließt sich eine weitere frage an wie ist dann dieses multiversum. Entstanden gab es ein
Multi knall umfasst ja was war dann nach vor die idee des multiversums scheint wirklich nicht überprüfbar zu sein deswegen
Gibt es auch im großen widerstand. Gegen die theorie
Dritte theorie und die ist wirklich ja ich würde mal sagen. Ein
Bisschen spooky das universum ist aus dem nichts entstanden
Die moderne physik ist mittlerweile der ansicht dass dinge tatsächlich aus dem nirgendwo
Entstehen können diese meinung ist spektakulär und galt in der wissenschafts community lange zeit als undenkbar das universum
Entstanden aus dem nichts genau davon gehen, mittlerweile. Einige wissenschaftlerinnen
Und wissenschaftler aus aber wie kann das sein ganz am anfang standen demnach
Wohl winzige energie geladene teilchen sogenannte quanten. Und jetzt gibt es auch schon ans eingemachte denn
Vielleicht ist ja dass es laut der quantenmechanik eigentlich gar. Keinen leeren raum
Geben kann doch die forschungsteams die an die entstehung des universums aus dem nichts glauben beziehen sich auf die quantengravitation
Danach ist die. Quantenmechanik mit der der quantengravitation
Vereint und somit sind zufällige und sehr kurze energie schwankung selbst in einem vakuum möglich in der fachsprache auch
quantenfluktuationen
Teilchen und das entsprechende anti teilchen entstehen spontan. Und löschen sich kurze. Zeit später
gegenseitig wieder aus doch eventuell
Kam es ja zu einer gleichverteilung also einem überschuss von materie antimaterie
Dann, wird, er tatsächlich vermutet nur keiner weiß warum es sie gab. Dann würde. Ein bisschen. Mehr materie bestehen bleiben
Und könnte so nach ansicht der forscherinnen forscher für den ganzen galaxien. Und sternen. Geführt haben wie wir sie. Heute aus dem universum. Kennen
Es ist schon eine klasse vorstellung denn. So eine kleine asymmetrie vor sehr langer zeit hätte. Dann
So viel materie erzeugt wie das universum heute beinhaltet doch diese
Theorie nachdem das universum aus dem nichts entstanden sein könnte wird
Heiß diskutiert doch fest steht auch fanden fluktuationen ja die sind messbar also
Experimentell gesichert möglich scheint es also schon dass das ganze als aus der lehre entstand alles in allem
kommen wir da aber an die grenzen unserer erkenntnisse und viele fragen zum beispiel der frage nach gott
Und dem ursprung von allem und vielleicht können wir diese erkenntnis grenzen überwinden wenn es allerdings. Neues dazu gibt. Dann erfahrt
Ihr es natürlich hier bei klingt und wenn ihr kein video dazu. Und zu allen anderen themen verpassen
Wollte die youtube aber ob sie funktioniert ja absolut na ja gar nicht eigentlich. Dann endet
Mich bei whatsapp nur dann verpasst er kein video über whatsapp erfahrt. Ihr von mir. Noch vor allen
Anderen, vom neuesten video täglich, um garantiert und zu brüsten habe ich. Ein kleines geschenk für euch einfach draufklicken
Und am besten auch. Meinen schwesterkanal klicks. Um
social media abonnieren da gibt es das neueste aus der social media welt
Wie aktuell über die anzeige gegen nebel nie wegen eines - total irre. Dafür hier
Kriegen aber nicht die schwimmer flocke vergessen. Und hier geht es weiter mit dafür auch draufklicken
sensation dunkle materie existiert wahrscheinlich nicht bis dann
bleibt dran